what's tomorrow by the way tell us
what's tomorrow's friday
jobs friday that's danielle's like super
bowl non-farm payroll friday yeah
everybody's a big deal
8 30 a.m eastern standard time everybody
has to be quiet
everyone in your house knows do not talk
to danielle on john's friday
so ready to be lied to by the federal
government here come the numbers
so from last time you were on till today
what are the jobs looking like
scarce damn i mean no look
there are so you want to get on this
right away yeah go for it
give it to us let's get into it no
matter what whether it's
across the midwest whether it's here in
florida just driving around whether it's
texas
you can't drive a block without seeing a
help wanted sign that's right there is a
massive under supply of labor in texas
right now
everywhere this is a nationwide
phenomenon because
they're federal unemployment benefits
that are being paid to people and
it makes no sense to work if you can get
paid to sit on your ass
for a lot more money and that's what
americans are doing right now this is so
not american what we're witnessing so
you're saying that but the numbers show
unemployment's you know
doing great economies growing no no no
there are a lot of people who are taking
jobs
but that does not take away from look at
what happened to small businesses during
the coronavirus
you got your big box retailers walmart
was allowed to stay open home depot
lowe's and all the small businesses had
to close and now
bigger companies amazon they can pay a
little bit more per hour
to bring these people off the sidelines
right small businesses can't do that
they don't have the funds and they can't
compete with these large
players so you screwed small businesses
during the coronavirus
you're screwing them now with federal
policy because they they cannot afford
to compete
for labor that wants to sit on its ass
i've seen things like mcdonald's is
paying paying 50 bucks
just to come back i'm getting 50 bucks
just to get an interest are you
kidding me no no no no you get i went i
got 50 bucks i got a couple i got a
happy meal
you make a hell of a drive-through
cashier oh yeah i think you'd kill it
that's your joke uh well uh
you wouldn't hit their 59 second time
but you would be like a four minute
drive through
it could take a while yeah productivity
would
crash at mcdonald's no question but
because you're safe you're sexual people
would want to hear from you
why don't you explain what that is ding
ding ding ding ding ding where did the
tell us about what's going on with the
job market so the job market right now
is hot we have
an under supply issue in america that is
being largely driven by china
china's got they're sitting on tons and
tons of steel they're the world's
largest steel producer by a magnitude of
10. it started with the trump
tweet that started the trade war that
really pissed him off
and then comes the coronavirus so we
what started with the supply chain
disruption
has become a disaster for american
manufacturers
they cannot source enough supply
so they're going to higher cost u.s
manufacturers to get these supplies
and they're trying to ramp up production
and they can't you see
ford has shut down production lines
chrysler has shut down production lines
because
they can't get the semiconductors and
whose
flying jets towards taiwan and who
controls the world's
semiconductor supply china and taiwan
taiwan semi so it's taiwan is huge it's
really so yes there are a l there's a
lot of demand right now in the united
states for jobs there's also
eight million people that we know have
not had their jobs come
back but there's also this massive
skills
mismatch right because if you're joe q
who used to work at
at name a retailer jcpenney
macy's that's been closed you've got a
certain skill set
you're not going to pick up and go work
in a factory it's just not going to
happen
and you're getting paid a lot to sit at
home between 17 and 20 bucks an hour
how sustainable is this how long can we
go like this
as a capitalist country
or a socialist country if we're if we're
in socialism we can go on like this
forever
we can just pay people to not work just
keep printing just keep printing the
money is that sustainable though to keep
printing money and pay people not to
work
china hopes it is china thinks it is
china hopes
hopes it is in america and yeah yeah
they want to see us bury ourselves
by the way with with socialist policies
i mean the irony
it it's inescapable but right now it
looks like we're going to see 998
thousand jobs two months in a row
basically of a million jobs created in
this country
right huge huge huge numbers what kind
of jobs are these are these
good jobs good paying jobs skill sets
needed you know four-year degree jobs or
the
entry level right now job openings for
people with
the least amount of education are up 60
percent okay
opening job opening opening right job
openings for people with
a college degree they're up maybe four
or five percent
so get out of here oh yeah okay but most
of those people didn't lose their jobs
remember they're they're doing fine
they're okay they've kept their jobs or
they got replaced at another place right
right they worked from home
and now the people who do have requisite
skill sets
are like at google are saying i'm not
coming back in the office you
if you force me to come back into the
office there's so many jobs out there
i'll quit well daniel question by the
way
just just an fy what she just said right
there is very accurate in interviews
people are saying that right now yeah
well we're interviewing people you know
what i'm talking about they'll sit there
we're interviewing
people engineers they'll say look yeah i
got five offers right now i can work
from home three days and two out of
office are you guys willing to match
that
yeah and they're very confident about
asking that question they're not like
sitting there
hey will you please do this now they're
like look here's what i'm expecting
three days home two days at the office
on the job in the sector
i mean some of the some of the jobs you
have no choice but to want to do it
because that's becoming the norm
in that industry but some of the jobs
you got to be at the office yeah
there are some jobs that are coders
engineers you know what we'll work
something out to make that happen but
not every job so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
you